[Music]
welcome everybody to the h3 podcast I
want to say live but it's actually not
live
this is our first not live episode since
like episode 20 and the reason for that
is that we've made a we have got the
wonderful and beautiful talented ever
the mr. beast let's start there I told
him I'd sue him it feels live yeah I
haven't seen the N word I just didn't
yeah no I totally understand yeah yeah
so we're going we're not live for the
purpose of being able to edit Jimmy now
that's not true it was here on an off
day and we we we had we actually have
like a tight schedule so we're gonna
Bank this app and you guys are gonna see
it in two weeks so if there's like some
catastrophic event that happens between
now and two weeks that we don't mention
that's why sorry about that guys yeah we
camera user and we're so sorry to all
the all the tragedy and our hearts go
out to everybody that we didn't was the
fact yeah that's impressed everybody
today's episode is sponsored by quick
calm ring and stamps.com Jimmy Donaldson
otherwise known as mr. piece on YouTube
known for his over-the-top stunts feats
and donation I love hearing how people
describe it you go
you like how did I scrub you good well
yeah you described yourself fool it was
just different every single time like
literally no one says the same thing you
do a lot you're all over the place actly
yes so like you could literally pick
anything like five different videos and
they're all different I would say I
would mostly describe you for
over-the-top stunts I think that that
describes yeah an overarching thing
over-the-top stunts I kind of like that
one trying to think like a MTV show yeah
what's something we did you know that we
did well it wasn't a stunt it's standing
spending 24 hours in a desert is that a
stunt I feel like that's a stunt okay
well then you might just solve my
problem I've never been to the stunt has
a weird notation it's giving a hundred
thousand dollars to a homeless shelter
stunt I think so because it doesn't I
see we're not like a negative yes if we
take either is maybe a slight negative
cause of the word for the stunt if we
remove that your showman your
gomen yeah it's so men that's it I've
always went over the top gags yeah there
we go
so anyway so what's up good man thank
you for coming here yep it's great to
see you're out here from North Carolina
right yes
so I filmed something yesterday and then
I have another thing I have to film on
Monday so it's like for the people
listening it's Saturday so you just fill
it up the time and I just chilling yeah
nice how do you like LA compared to it's
like honestly the weather has been crazy
like just how nice it is cuz in North
Carolina it was freezing and I like to
walk I'm just really random so like
three months a year in North County I
can't walk but if I lived here I would
like good I wish all year long yeah well
I'm jealous
well that's what you know that's what we
pay 50% taxes here for yeah and more for
rent and employees and everything yeah
like oh I have a warehouse that we film
out of and like if I had that same
warehouse here it would be like probably
like eight times the cost per month okay
so you probably have a huge warehouse
that you shoot stuff exactly yeah
so let me put it in perspective cuz I am
actually I think you're right like it
would cost like $50,000 I think you're
right yeah big warehouses like that are
only used by like huge fulfillment
factories yeah and they like maximize
every square foot exactly yeah so that
in and of itself is just not feasible
and then all the employees would be more
and in my office space and stuff I just
like I think broke yeah what you what
you've built kind of reminds me of dude
perfect in a sense that you're doing
like these big stunts there's a bunch of
crew and a ton of space they're also
like in the South right or more open I
have no idea honestly I mean they're
like but there's this kind of like the
same for the most part you know
sports-related we're just like whatever
yeah no it's sure they also have like a
huge warehouse just to put in
perspective this office here we pay
3,000 a month for um that's actually
pretty good I think so yeah
so it's like two rooms mm-hmm yeah but
in North Carolina like a seven room
office like is only like 1800 a month so
what do you pay for a rent can I ask
that I'm just curious what I mean that's
one of ours your house like what's your
what do you
I have no idea honestly my mom got it
for me oh this oh that's sweet I like
the more we talked the more you realize
I like I do YouTube and that's about it
you know I kind of like I like to
delegate stuff to other people so I can
focus on it we were talking about that
before we started recording and I was
asking about your shirt and TV yeah yeah
and I was like oh that like vintage but
it looks new that's a cool shirt yeah
just ask me questions about my shirt and
I was like I didn't buy this I also had
someone do shopping for me I suck at
fashion I literally suck at anything I'm
not YouTube I thought that was really
interesting that you have like a stylist
basically you you outsource everything
that's not video making in your life
kind like I mean at the moment since
we're blowing up it's optimal to spend
the time doing that yeah we know do you
have a housekeeper someone who takes
care they blimey I just yeah [ __ ] yeah
dude yeah mom yeah but no I think what's
cool about it is that you from the
beginning you're kind of treating it
like business right right that was 12
making minecraft videos I guess not from
the beginning yeah I know Jimmy and like
once I started yeah it was like two
years ago I got my first employee and
then from there just snowballed yeah but
I think it's really mean ela is starting
to realize this it's so smart when you
have money and you're super busy their
own the best thing a lot of people I see
buying expensive clothes and cars and
houses and doing [ __ ] the best thing you
can do with your money is buy yourself
more time
oh yeah exactly just by how basic if you
can free an hour of your own time of day
by paying someone to do something
whatever amount that is it's worth it
well if you're a youtuber like it's kind
of opportunity cost I mean if it's right
hundred dollars to free up a few hours
that you can put towards a video and
you're pulling millions of views I mean
it's like a no-brainer just yeah exactly
it's opportunity cost yeah
so you figured out something that took
us so long a much longer time
generation of youtubers who do it all
themselves great yes yeah that was the
attitude when we came up it was like all
you like all exactly don't have any
tears or and that's what I edited like
my first like eight hundred videos
myself and I remember like thinking ah
no one will ever be able to match my
style all that other crap everyone says
but then you get an editor and it's like
I was stupid like why was I doing right
it's one of those things where cuz like
you could put that time into making your
next video that's what I tell every
youtuber that edits our videos like I
mean I haven't been able to find an
editor although actually I found some
really good editors but my problem is
that I'm super inconsistent we were my
post
yeah but part time editors mm-hmm I kept
[ __ ] it's so hard people need I could
actually show you like when you get a
new editor you just wanna the first
video to edit you just literally want to
sit behind them and watch them and just
critique them and you want to do that a
few times and after a while they just
get the rhythm of your style yeah like
you just do like a couple reviews before
they go live you 100% should it makes no
sense for you to edit your own videos
yeah I know but I do it's such a shame I
think like not on the podcast though
well when we had like on the main
channel yeah oh I did edit a couple of
the podcasts the first episodes myself
with five cameras bro is the worst
we always quit the podcast yeah well you
got a solid crew out there now there
they are they're truly the best San in
and Zak yeah what uh what juicy stuff do
you have planned for us any any fun this
is it yeah this is juicy
yeah I'm juicing up okay I'm gonna
bucket a slime for 24 hours right now
there I would not recommend that
I give me a rash really yeah what kind
of rash we talking about like literally
like on my chest and stuff it took like
two weeks ago I yeah no that was
terrible
it was freezing and I mean like I had to
pee in the slime too because I can leave
oh yeah so so you're almost like when
you pee in slime it's almost like it
doesn't really go away from you does it
yeah I don't want to talk about it I
would never do did you fit in the slide
no no that would be too funny like right
before I got it I did so I didn't have
to worry about it that's good yeah it's
uh sometimes like you start a challenge
thinking it's not gonna be as hard
you're like you're already halfway
through so you're like I might as well
[ __ ] finish you know my last 12 hours
yeah but if you could tell yourself
you'd be like yeah you probably
shouldn't do that yeah yeah but that's
that's your craft man yeah just what's
art that's how like literally half my
challenges go like I think they're
easier than they are but then I get so
far into it I'm like might as well
finish yeah it kind of sucks
yeah but the year suffering is
entertaining is the beauty of the whole
damn thing and yeah yeah I mean you have
the best mr. B's the video of the beast
the beauty oh the beauty of the bees oh
is that my mom okay my mom sure to take
shredder away so didn't like that joke
yeah it's not your first video that kind
of like correct me if I'm wrong are you
gonna count to a hundred thousand that
took off right yes everyone always says
that I don't know why I just what was
your first big video I thought that was
the big one I mean there's so many ones
here and there but yeah that was how
worst one like really big one yeah in
the YouTube community cuz everyone was
kind of like slightly clowning on me for
doing it but like 50% of people like wow
that took a lot of effort he has Drive
and then other people were just like
what a [ __ ] idiot right most but
they're both true kind of yeah yeah no
it doesn't bother me yeah so I remember
like faze clan like in one of their
blogs like all the phase members were
like reacting to it which puts in
perspective because like I hang out with
them a lot now but back then I was like
holy crap yeah he's clean I got my video
and stuff like that yeah so it's like
it's crazy because now actually they
they compete in a lot of my videos like
the last move circle in the barrel
that's funny you probably grew up
watching youtubers and wanting to be one
because you're doing like Minecraft and
literally like from 12 to now like I
mean all I did is YouTube actually a lot
of people I hang out with a lot of my
friends like they always make movie
references and stuff like I literally
just grew up on YouTube and I haven't
seen so it must be really like kind of a
magical surreal thing to become a
youtuber well you're like a top-tier
youtuber yeah exactly no it is cuz it's
like it's hard because I know like
99.99% of people listening don't really
know my past and stuff like that so they
wouldn't be able to imagine it but it's
like I mean yeah 12 13 14
fifteen sixteenths I'm grinding YouTube
everyday not getting anywhere 1718
things start happening 1920 I blow up
but it's like there's so many times
where I went to bed I'm just like am I
just wasting all my time you know like I
never thought I'd blow up well you're
young you're a young dude with a bunch
of ambition from a young age like yeah
so in your case you you put so much time
and effort and energy and it's nice
because you started at an age where you
didn't really have anything to lose
yeah well I didn't even know you can
make money and you know yeah I was just
doing it because I really wanted to do
it so that's what I like if I'm patting
myself on the back just that I've just
done it did you ever have to get a real
job no I've never
I was I was this opposed to working out
hard he's one time because I'm wanting
money to like buy more equipment and
stuff but then I started making a little
more cuz I I remember I used to make
like a dollar a day off my channel me I
just save it up for months and then I
bought like a microphone and things like
that good times I remember uh yeah we I
remember making my first hundred because
you can take it out you got a hundred
and I made a video of me on the [ __ ]
with my thought without pants but my fat
thighs covering everything and and
YouTube D monetized it
I think they age-restricted it oh [ __ ]
back then was so weird the monetization
probably wasn't a thing back then it was
age restriction yeah yeah that's how
those were the best days weren't they
yeah oh my god you have to really sit
naked on a toilet do you get him on it
dude I've missed those days there was no
like Oh am I gonna get demonetized like
unless you didn't show your dick
unblurred you were gonna make it's
honestly kind of insane to think how
unrestricted it was because you could
and one day sign up a new channel and
then be making money from it yeah like
that is kind of unfathomable and people
have literally re uploaded videos and
stuff like that no one cares well and
there was probably a problem with like
people putting Isis videos and like
child pornography and [ __ ] like that and
then putting ads on it so you know there
was four there was probably a need for
some reform but for demonisation oh of
course yeah I mean like if not we
wouldn't make a fraction will you make
now but it's a it it's like you know so
media's new I think a lot of people
forget so like a lot of people would
hate on YouTube but you gotta fail for
the most part to learn dude i my
feelings on youtube are very ambivalent
because I complain about YouTube a lot
less now yes but they what they do every
day and what they've achieved is so
freakin insane and let us remember that
they pay creators fifty five percent of
their earnings since they started
putting since they started this program
and they have not been profitable maybe
up until like only a year ago yeah so
it's not like Netflix membership or
office and they're like it went up from
12 to we take more now sucker
yeah I don't think they would ever do
that but to be fair like I think part of
alphabets stock valuation like 150
billion of it isn't like towards YouTube
last time I read so like they've made
the money back through stock even though
they're not mappable and a lot of
nonprofit II is through the account with
you you're like a number you don't
understand [ __ ] yeah I was that about
are you uh if you went to college what
wouldn't you have studied well I was
going for like our tea break we went to
call you Leafly for two weeks yeah and
then I stopped going and I didn't tell
my mom for a little bit and then counted
a hundred thousand because I was like is
when I stopped going I just like I had
no future out so you do so you stopped
and then did the hundred thousand you
did the thousand and I think it was
after I was like I was like literally
like I gotta make this work so I was
like I was doing everything I could like
was that a tough time in your life cuz
it sounds like there was a lot of
friction between like what you wanted
out of life and the expectations of the
people around you like my mom yeah yeah
no I mean my mom is nice she actually
loves me but it's funny cuz she's like
she had to act tough and she's like go
to college or move out and so then I
moved out after that but that's like
she's super nice that's a tough position
to be in as a parent like you gotta
appreciate exactly she just wants me to
be successful so like I understand and
like she's like so nice it's funny like
that she like acted Stern like you have
you know but yeah and then it was it was
just interesting but I was like I was so
motivated like I mean I would stay up
all night just thinking of ideas like
lots of times and stuff like that so
like it just I don't know I
I'm glad I did it cuz like without it I
just wouldn't have had the time and just
uh well you just don't have anything
else you just you just go hard you know
what I mean I don't know how else to put
it
know what I mean yeah well when I was um
it's a beautiful age dude because you
there's nothing you can just commit
yourself to something like later in life
like when I started doing YouTube I had
a day job and helos in school and but
didn't that drive that you have at the
beginning is like endless I had the
drive but I didn't have endless time
yeah right no I think about what drive
is the drive is what matters and I guess
is true because you you make the time
but when I was your age I was playing
video games 15 hours a day and I
remember thinking like I try to pick up
those games now mm-hmm I don't the
[ __ ] time to enjoy this because this
is that beautiful time in your life yeah
when you're like 13 no I agree Aventine
when you can just commit fifteen hours a
day to something yeah I think most
Americans to have that kind of time and
they just like they just convinced
themselves in the head they don't you
know what I mean like so good you can
mentally procrastinate like crazy like I
can spend an hour on the couch on my
phone and then be like [ __ ] yeah I think
anything done today why busy all day you
know like yeah you really anyone
listening to this probably spends an
hour plus a day on Instagram and Twitter
and you cut that out like your life
would be no different like for the worse
and you would have a free hour to like
do whatever but yeah it's just you gotta
you got to want something to do with
that free hour though yeah I actually
speak since our time about the hustle I
love when people like grind on YouTube
for like a year or two and they're like
oh it's impossible and then well I'm
like that's rookie numbers since we're
on the subject you know absolutely for I
mean that's rookie numbers for any
pursue right like the people that you
know there's been channels that blow up
like immediately super big and as um
maybe you've noticed this almost every
time that they fall off like pretty
quickly too I mean leafies like the
classic example yes someone that like
blew up super [ __ ] fast trying to
think who else I know what you're talk
up alai don't I don't want to like yeah
you don't I don't want to name names
yeah your channel's [ __ ] dead yeah
but some people blow up and stay blown
up well four is killing it of course
no that happens a lot too yes but to the
people that blow up immediately and
stable up [ __ ] them yeah but it's true
if you're if you're doing anything
creative or trying to pursue anything
that requires like you to be more
successful than a lot of other people
competing to do the same thing you got
to put in the time energy man yeah and
you have to work smarter not harder I
mean some people I I say this analogy a
lot but it since we're on the topic I
think for most smaller channels like if
they're pulling a thousand views of
video and they upload a video every day
for a hundred days they'll pull hundred
thousand views but I would recommend you
just think of a really good idea one
that people genuinely want to watch put
a lot of [ __ ] time into the video and
you could pull a hundred thousand views
in a week you kind of see what I'm
saying is I've most people that I talked
to because I like to counsel small
channels sometimes just get in the
motions of just whatever you know and
it's just like if you just took a step
back I haven't even upload in the last
week I don't care you know it's not like
it's that big of a deal like and you
just make a kick-ass video like you
could like pull exponentially so many
more views you know with so much less
effort you know yeah it's interesting
there's definitely if there's different
approaches that like PewDiePie who does
you know daily his format is something
that's kind of hard to duplicate to be
honest well I mean he's yeah it's pretty
incredible what he's achieved on his
channel but then I think there's a big
craving now on YouTube that I'm noticing
for people for high quality long-form
content where before I feel like maybe a
year or two ago the people are NSP what
was favoring at least in the algorithm
possibly yeah just frequent ten-minute
uploads every day you know yeah partly I
don't know if that many people were
doing long-form super high quality
content that was the thing I think it's
more than you like is the whole big
budget type videos and I've seen it
start to pop up a lot more recently yeah
yeah so it's like it's because like if
someone the way I like to look at it
like if if someone does put a lot of
time into a video and a lot of money and
all this stuff like of course it's gonna
get more views than if someone just like
does a Q&A on their couch so yeah like
when people say like well why are
long-form videos that are you know
really high production all of a sudden
doing well now it's cuz like it's more
interesting like if you only have 15
minutes you're gonna invest it in the
big video not this little one that just
they mumble and I guess the cynical part
of people is like you would hope that it
would get more views but sometimes on
YouTube it's like dark magic you never
know what's actually gonna pop but I
mean certainly on the whole people are
gonna want to watch yeah well what yeah
it depends yeah they don't know how to
package the contents yeah that's a nice
man I'd say I've seen that no it's not
it's not I've seen video really
incredible videos of people doing
long-form like unbelievable feats like
this one guy I saw he built a [ __ ]
house out of Orbeez and uh really and
like that's actually really Iceland yeah
where it was like negative you know 50
degrees and he they built like these
drywall and they put Orbeez in it froze
it salt and they remove it like that and
there was lights in the Orbeez and I was
they did it clearly over the course of
months but it was shot like ass yeah
there was no like narrative so you're
saying it underperformed it do to have
like 50,000 views really it was a very
unfortunate was a low-performing video
even for his channel and I think it's
because he just there's no story the
packaging was bad yeah I'd have to look
at him but chances are like that have a
video go viral you need people need to
watch it for a really long time and
high-percentage need to click on it so
yes it sounds like people it's long
watched time and that's true you're
right it's really just a formula of of
clicking and yeah watch it I mean like
people overcomplicate the algorithm like
if people click on your video and watch
your video what the [ __ ] else does
YouTube want like they don't care about
comments or likes now that matters they
don't know click and watch yeah that's a
you're right it really is that simple
yeah I know it's it's funny because
people tell me oh there's an algorithm
shift two months ago and this and that
like what are you going on about you
don't like their core principles have
been the same for like the last six
years
mmm I want to I want to ask you some
more questions after this commercial
break
oh okay so we will be right back I've
just I want to ask you about thumbnails
and titles because you are master
of that and I love talking about yeah so
we'll be right back after this
commercial break that is actually
instant for us but takes only a couple
minutes for you because this is in life
step you're brushing up to the next
level with quip electric toothbrush
first of all electric toothbrushes are
the way you want to brush your teeth
that much has been established by the
dentist by the dentist's forever but
here's the deal you get a vibrating
toothbrush that packs a punch and a
little tube like this starting at
twenty-five dollars is gonna get you the
vibration of a two hundred dollar
toothbrush and here's the deal also I
only use this quip and I'll tell you why
the bristle heads are so soft and so
gentle on my gums ah dude I'm a
toothbrush connoisseur I have bought
dozens of softs head brushes and this is
among the very best because you can get
everywhere it doesn't hurt your gums it
gives you a perfect brush and that's an
addition to it vibrating and then a
pulsates and tells you when to switch
sides to make sure you're getting that
perfect two-minute brush that the
dentists demand you get because let's
face it breath is the most important
thing when it comes to mating if you got
stinky breath if you got a nasty mouth
you never have a chance give this a shot
it starts at $25 this qyp electric
toothbrush is gonna change and elevate
your brushing game so it's backed by
20,000 dental professionals but i
endorsed it so what the hell does it
matter what they think quip starts at
just $25 go to get quick comm /h through
right now and you'll get a refill pack
this and a little tube of toothpaste for
free with a quip electric toothbrush so
give it a shot get your first refill
pack free at GE tqu IP comm / h3y
does life have to be so stressful it's
too complicated we have too many
responsibilities too many things to do
it could drive someone crazy that's why
it's so important to remain calm stress
and anxiety many people often feel
exhausted during the day when it's time
to go to bed
they can't even fall asleep if you worry
it's affecting your days and your nights
it's probably also affecting our health
that's why we've partnered with God
that's calm the number one app to help
reduce your anxiety and stress and help
you sleep better more than 40 million
people around the world have downloaded
if you had to calm calm /h 3 you're
gonna get 25% off a comp premiums
subscription which includes guided
meditations on issues like anxiety
stress and focus including a brand new
media and meditation everyday they also
have sleep stories which are bedtime
stories for adults designed to help you
relax they even have soothing music and
so right now h3 listeners get 25% off a
comp premiums subscription at Kham Kham
/ h3 that's e-a-l m.com / h3 get
unlimited access to all of calms content
today at com.com
/ h3 get calm and pleased by by golly
stop stressing give a show
[Music]
you're a busy person why on earth would
you even consider going to the post
office when you have futuristic options
available to you like doing postage
online
that's what stamps calm is all about one
of the most popular time-saving tools
for small businesses
Sam's comm eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office you simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send once your mail
is ready you just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in a mailbox it's
that simple
if you're if you got big or small
amounts of quantity they can handle
whatever you got and with stamps time
you get five cents off every first-class
stamp and up to 40% off Priority Mail
that's a discount you can't even get at
the post office step so comes a
no-brainer it saves you both time and
money it's no wonder that over 700
thousand small businesses already use
stamps calm and if it doesn't get any
better than that my listeners get a
special offer that includes four week
trial plus free spa stitch and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps com click on the
mogrify no microphone at the top of the
homepage at type h3 that stamps comm go
to the top of the page where the
microphone is click that and enter h3
for this beautiful special offer enjoy
there's a couple of products that have
literally changed my life and ring is
one of them I feel so much safer so much
more secure with the ring I have like 6
rings around my house and it is just a
lifesaver
what ring is is they've got doorbells
they got spotlights they've got motion
detectors they got all these gadgets
that have cameras on them they've got
two-way talking on them it's got motion
detectors so if somebody approaches your
house you get a motion on your phone
real-time and then you watch it and
here's the brilliant part about it it
zips it uploads that onto the Internet
so if one of these criminals is turning
off the power or disconnecting anything
it already gets blasted up to the cloud
you got their face you've got the
notification on your phone
no matter where you are in the world
ring is a beautiful ultimate Prada
that has literally transformed my life
and I'm so prettier than I love it so
much I cannot recommend enough great
place to start is the ring doorbell it's
a doorbell with a camera and a two-way
talking is ridiculous so but we also
have a special offer for you here as a
listener you have a special offer for
the ring starter kit available right now
with a video doorbell and
motion-activated floodlight cam that's
enough to bring to build a ring of
security around your home that is
impenetrable and you're gonna feel a
heck a lot more safe love this product
just go to ring.com /h flu that's ring
comm / h3 give it a shot I mean this is
phenomenal stuff here guys give it a
shot for Christ's sake
welcome back everybody I really like
that company man they're great off dude
their brand mm-hmm super strong I'm
gonna buy it
yeah you should thank you and use the
code h3 well do for whatever it was on
the screen sometimes it's not that
so you I could tell looking at your
videos
you're a thumbnail thumbnail man yeah
someone some in art it's some in our
athletes come in our thumbnail tell me
about your do you have a philosophy when
it comes with thumbnails I definitely
know that you will go far out of your
way to capture it right yeah well I mean
like we do crazy videos so you want to
you know you want to optimize it so it
does well so I can recoup most part when
I spend on a lot of these videos but it
would help if you asked a little more
specific like which videos are stuff
like that well I was watching the one
with the glowing sword specifically yeah
and so were you cut in half of the car
yeah cut in half the car yeah we
attempted to I I thought it would work I
don't know why but it didn't well yeah I
don't know why but you guys went out
into a field and then for the thumbnail
you took a picture of yeah Conan the
Barbarian cutting the car in half for a
good thumbnail yeah so I was just
wondering you know do you do you
frequently go that far out of your way
were you to capture the thumb yeah I
mean of course everyone should I mean if
people don't flick they don't watch so
you want to give them something to click
yeah but for the most part I mean some
are a little fluff but we try to
represent the video and I feel like we
do so I mean there's nothing bad about
it you know what I mean because just
when people talk about thumbnails
usually there's a negative kind of thing
oh I admire your thumbnail game it's
really good my thumbnail names [ __ ] my
thumbnail game is awful what was your
new video it had like a blue background
I'll show you yeah I just I remember
seeing it and kind of actually liking it
I just thought oh you did like it yeah
okay we got the stamp of approval yeah
morning million views easily no didn't
do that well it under Wow leave that one
3350 packs of pop rocks that's a banger
mat stony you know that guy no I don't
know days ago I just know by looking at
that I know that's gonna get a lot of
use
dude that's four days ago Matt stony we
got it dude you got competition
I need to fill a pool of pop rocks what
up I'm just kidding um this one yeah
let's try kissing man my problem with
this thumbnail is that you don't watch
your own video this is not an account
that we actually watched at I watched it
like 20 times my problem with this
thumbnail is that you don't you don't
know it's our video yeah um I don't know
I that we'd have to have a longer
conversation about I mean if if I was
trying to give you advice but uh I mean
that type of stuff works well leafy
didn't you know did thumbnails like that
everyone knows as him like everyone's
seeing that seizure name it knows that
you you know what I mean it's not yeah
it's like most your thumbnails don't
really have your face so like no they
don't
yeah so people are just always looked at
about well anyway yeah yeah that's
overthinking it at that point it really
doesn't matter alright so um I guess
thumbnails since I was it's just uh you
know you just want to make something I
think if we're giving it by something a
lot of people forget is like uncertain
on phones thumbnails are really [ __ ]
small so like people are editing
thumbnails full-blown on their new year
and when you shrink it down you can't
see all these little things so yeah we
do that we may always do that I always
make you like tiny then there you go
perfect yeah I like to just like take a
screenshot of my phone and then just put
my thumbnail over a thumbnail and then I
can just see what it looks like so
that's how you get your thumbnail over a
thumbnail yeah exactly and then just
look at on your phone and just be like
if I was a normal person what I care to
clean on it yeah
the thing that always gets me to is they
put like the the amount of duration on
the bottom right and the time step yeah
it always like covers text exactly
that's why you never put text in the
bottom right yeah yeah I want to ask you
some questions about specific videos
yeah hit me here we go we've been
talking a lot about salt Bay on arch on
our podcast recently because I feel like
he's kind of a culinary fraud I don't
think that guy knows how to cook a damn
thing based on based on he wasn't at the
restaurant when I was there so I didn't
meet him yeah it's fine I'm not asking
you to take down salt bay that's my
personal opinion
but I what but I am curious because here
you guys spent well this you guys spend
a thousand dollars on a gold covered
tomahawk yes yeah
now does that what tell me about does
that gold actually honestly I didn't
really taste it yeah it's kind of there
for show yeah it's a it's a hard flex
yeah it's a hard hard hard to be fair
this was this is a flexing this is
showing you guys what the experience did
I'm not accusing you of anything I'm
it's all pays restaurant
yeah no the video was great and clearly
paid for itself with 17 million views oh
wow yeah that's actually pretty good I
should go up by like a gold covered
lobster or something well you guys dude
the thumbnail was crazy on this one you
had to click it yeah and it was me like
about to eat it yeah I had to make
everything about someone else and stuff
but this one was just uh most people
don't get experience it's like expensive
restaurants and no one really does so
you thought it'd be cool to to watch how
would you rate it
Oh ten thousand dollar meal over well if
that was inflated cuz like I literally
like told them like can and like I say
it in the video so I'm not hiding
anything but like I would told him like
charge me more so I can put ten thousand
a month so that was nowhere near ten
thousand I just made them charge me a
lot more but it was alright I mean not
worth it yeah I ate like at some what
his Korean barbecue place last night it
was like just as good yeah yeah well I
mean it's for a restaurant to actually
serve out of it though to order that on
a rock I know you guys are ordering fear
yeah I'm not saying about you but you
have to be kind of a [ __ ] mean I know
that I live on you and everything like
that I hate I hate when people hate me
bro they [ __ ] so I've been watching
videos of Saul pace and whenever someone
gets a beep the editing Salieri's both
shout out to Ethan or Bailey's they
force-feed you yep look at this it's
like hello I just spent a thousand
dollars just [ __ ] don't make me feel
like a baby while I'm at it
like how deep does he put his [ __ ]
finger
alright enough with the glove that's
kind of gross
I don't want to [ __ ] talking about they
were incredibly nice oh you know I got
to I will okay yeah I always thought
[ __ ] I'm Sophie yeah
he's a [ __ ] I don't want that glove
in my mouth why dude he could have not
he could have stopped like the meat was
in enough that oh you spent $1,000 here
let me finger your mouth with a dirty
glove but what if that's what we wanted
well like you already admitted it Howie
you honor I mean I might have just been
insecure but now I'm coming out about it
you want any finger your mouth now I've
seen I've seen Vicky always does this he
always Morse feeds people with the gold
oh yeah yeah he did it to Bradbury's the
Bradbury's with the salt bay
oh they fought and they force-fed them
as well yeah this vendetta runs deep but
it's almost like a it's almost like a
fetish for them this is the big one the
thousand-dollar
t-bone tomahawk I think or I don't know
the cost I think it was a thousand I
watched it they were saying Wow
yeah I was just kind of like I was just
telling them give me the $10,000 cuz I
get this point I knew I had a video but
I didn't want to lie in the title so
she's like so I also got a Tomahawk
cruise for someone else I felt out for
two other people yeah it was a little
kid video sorry that's funny
it's funny that you just eat gold
I don't I still don't understand it but
I turned out like a heavy metal what's
the nutritional bro I literally [ __ ] go
now that the biggest flex ever
take a different video we've been on
this game for it's just something that
we yeah like something like we about to
force-feed you know don't I I didn't
like it like I'm not a big fan of that
type of stuff
what above the video no no when people
force alright feed me you know thank you
[Laughter]
next up okay this one I have to wonder
okay so in this video put a hundred
million Orbeez in your friend's backyard
and I've wondered this about every or be
video I've ever watched yep but this one
specifically because has anyone ever
done a bigger or B feet than this on
youtube I don't because this was like
incredibly hard to do I just don't even
think anyone has the resources to do it
100 million yeah it took like like this
is a video that took like three months
in the works like just to get the Orbeez
from China oh yeah so like I mean it was
like forever that was in the works and
they're like just we had to pick him up
from the port and then moving them there
and I'm packed for real yeah it was like
that was like you bought all the Orbeez
important yeah yeah and like and they
kept thinking we weren't being serious
we were like yeah we want a hundred
million and they're like you want 10
million no 109 it was like it was hard
but paid off oh yeah but honestly it was
is a lot and then like it took so many
face to film and set up and we uh we
were like I'll take a day to lay them
all out and it's like a days gone and
we've only done like 20 million and it
was it was just painful and then it took
like three weeks to pick them all up so
that's my question
yeah is let me show this video for all
of our viewers there are so many fun
this is not a small pool this is a
massive pool and the whole backyard is
covered yeah so how about [ __ ] do you
clean that yeah yeah yeah I mean shovels
and buckets literally just three weeks
you said of shovels and buckets yeah and
what do you dispose how you get rid of
it
we had a waste company help us with
honestly I'm not too familiar with the
logistics I don't know you had other
people doing yeah yeah that's now also
I'm quick you don't get wet when you're
in it it looks like you guys are dry
yeah it was oddly weird like our feet
would get wet but like the thing is if
you dive headfirst and that you would
like to literally get stuck and possibly
suffocate for real yeah cuz you can't
like it's heavy
yeah well you have to like use every
muscle in your body for like five
minutes just don't get across the pool
like we're legit like a solid you just
learnt like whenever you move the Orbeez
just more fill in the spot so you never
go anywhere it's swimming in a pool of
Orbeez something everyone should try
once in a life or can we skip that one I
think it's good for exercise it's a big
workout to get across the pool but the
cleanup is not really worth it so now
we're good
I have a feeling a lot of people who do
or be stones just like dumping it like
oh god I hope we didn't I hope we
disposed them I think we did now you're
good you guys are good you you're good
kids you got people yeah I mean what do
you do with it anyway yeah yeah for
example this video works so a lot of it
is part-time people yeah especially for
something like this just pay people by
the hour to take up for these together
but full-time I think I'm like 10 at the
moment oh wow that's a pretty big team
do you are you managing them or do you
have someone kind of yeah I think so
it's kind of nice cuz like little
stuff's getting done even though I'm
over here what are their titles like for
example I mean it's kind of like [ __ ]
number one and you have like and so you
have your own company that I assume
you're the president of and you have
like a manager that manages the staff
and everything like that I mean yeah but
at the end of day it's us [ __ ] around
the YouTube video so it's like it's
serious but it's not what it is you know
what like what's one like ordering water
than tipping $30,000 you know we just
went around doing that or I gave them
one time I give them an hour to spend a
hundred grand you know like so like is
it really work you come in and you spend
a hundred grand yeah so I've noticed a
lot of the times
like cash incentives in your videos for
the people a lot a lot of no no I mean
like everybody is that like one of the
ways of your compensation in a sense
like do they all are on salaries and I
mean that's all just bonus yeah exactly
so bro what is your what are your tax is
like because you give away so much money
I hope that that's all deductible I do
too
if it's not that is brutal if it's not
I'm I have a go fund me but we'll see
cuz this year's taxes are coming up and
that's when it's gonna I mean like
millions of about define yeah I'm gonna
be bad you got it yeah exactly I mean we
have it all documented we have receipts
and stuff but it's like the hard part is
like when I give my boys 100 grand to
spend like I just brought that up that
video of who pays taxes on it right damn
they can't pay taxes on it so then I
guess I have to pick one but it's not I
gave away the money so it's like it's
rough if I was your accountant and I'm
not at all they all come outside all the
taxes on my voice but like that's kind
of shitty no you don't they tell you
what like someone has to pay taxes and
yeah give my money either they say and
you're in the video you're like here's
$40,000 someone has to pay taxes on that
yeah exactly either me or them for the
most part so I don't know how that's
getting and that's even like if you go
give like a homeless dude a house is
there tax implications on that yeah I'm
pretty sure it's getting people don't
think about that yeah I know people need
to know about that
well we're gonna find out when this tax
season happens I want to find that mr.
Bies is gonna be your craziest like tax
yeah of course yeah last year it was
stupid the amount of money we spent I
mean like someone's like 500 grand on
videos so it's it's gonna be dumb I
don't I don't know how it's gonna go I
wasn't really so like game shows if you
win a car I didn't know this but
apparently right after the game show
they have you signed a document where
you say like you're gonna pay the $8,000
tax on it or you forfeit the prize like
you don't even get it at all like you
don't you do they don't even give it to
you to sell for real yeah like you
either pay taxes or not cuz I'd talk to
someone who was on a game show and he
won a prize and didn't even get to keep
it yeah about prices right yeah like you
win $100,000 vacation you're like
exactly it's more like you owe us
$50,000 yeah I think that's why they do
vacations because you can't liquidate it
so then
most people don't even take the fries
are you [ __ ] my all right I don't
know if most people don't but yeah so
that's where it makes things a little
weird on me because like you know if I
make them pay taxes on stuff and I look
like a piece of [ __ ] but if I pay taxes
on it on something that's already not
really proud hold on hold on there's
yeah I don't think because it's really
when we're talking about your staffers
yeah okay well other besides them I know
is so your staffer should pay tax
because for them it's like a but yeah
now if we're talking about like here you
go up to a waitress and you give her
$30,000 I even live like that one they
would pay taxes it's a little more messy
when I give someone a car I guess they
have to claim that yeah yeah that one's
a neat one it's more like literally like
I gave like six cars it's like who pays
taxes on these like 40 30 20 I wonder if
there's not room for an argument that
it's just a tax deduction for you
because it's part of your it's part it's
it'll see it's kind of like a an expense
yeah it's an experience of doing
business but I'm pretty sure someone has
died I hope you have a slick accountant
yeah we're gonna find out I hope you
look Jewish accountant with a Brooklyn
accent yeah well do you I don't
[ __ ] I just signed over to a slick
Jewish accountant with the Brooklyn he
dude yeah yeah I need one of those I
think I have one of those I don't deal
with the other I hope we don't have a
friend I hope well yeah this year he's
gonna save us a lot in taxes I have a
friend in show business who was pretty
big in show biz who recommended him to
me and I get on the phone his name's
like Harvey and he sounds like straight
out of the [ __ ] corner deli and
Brookland just like that deep Jewish
accent yeah and I was like how old are
you dude cuz he sounded like an old
Jewish man he's like I'm 40 I was like
bro you have the cadence of an old
Jewish man and you have my business yeah
all right yeah that's an anecdote that
you I can help you Joshua you can help
me I story short you can help me thank
you actually speaking of taxes I was
talking to someone I won't name them but
you know like Trump like passed the new
tax but weird like when a yeah and
you're supposed to like make it where
like you know
income people pay less and hire people
pay whatever like the you know make
companies pay less or whatever something
like that but I was talking to one of my
friends and it's funny cuz he ended up
paying like over like half a million
dollars less and he would have before
that tax bill and his employees actually
ended up paying like 5% more in taxes
but Trump pitched it like it was the
opposite so I've been obsessively
learning about that it's so so it's not
the law so the 1i Nene is the new
deduction and it's a 20 percent
corporate tax deduction yeah so and then
so first of all what they also did to
pay for that is remove the state income
tax so there's certain states mostly
liberal states that have a high personal
income tax to the state California New
York specifically I don't know what it's
like in North Carolina if is like five
percent so in California and the five
percent there that was a huge huge
deduction that would come from your
federal taxes and so on states like that
your taxes for for a lot of people are
actually gonna be going up and they also
capped personal expense to ten thousand
to so a lot of court not in corporations
yeah for your personal deductions so a
lot of people in blue states are gonna
have their taxes increased and they also
did this was he did us dirty dude
entertainers people who derived their my
malaria and stuff yeah people who derive
their their income from performance yeah
we're like it's a personality based uh
okay company cannot take the deduction
that ten thousand straight up the twenty
percent you cannot take it entertainers
here entertainers cannot take it and
then not only entertainers like lawyers
and accountants and [ __ ] like that like
professionals but he specifically went
after like that he went after like
entertainers specifically like a little
revenge play well see now we're getting
out of my realm of knowledge I don't
know anything yeah yeah there's no funny
stories where my friends who were
supposed to yeah you know people that
were supposed to be helping pay more and
it's just like I just like I'm not a
political person I know nothing about
politics but when they just blatantly
lie
and you know it's kind of like wow you
know well I talked to it it's so [ __ ]
up like when that happened I was like
yeah I'm I'm gonna get all this money
off taxes and then our accountants are
like no you're gonna pay more than
yourself what the [ __ ] yeah because
we're in it because I should just like
literally text you Juicin you should
find out what he's doing yeah well I I
just if I it's not easy if I didn't play
him properly oh I thought that was the
guy out there that shows um it's it's a
Lance Stewart I live on a bush yeah but
if I didn't prepare par properly you're
just gonna see my videos come from a
hundred thousand dollars of video down
to like five yeah today we're gonna be
giving out a packs of gum I don't think
you're a big spender I'm sure you're not
on yourself yeah I mean but it's all
business you're spending money on your
business so you gotta make sure someone
has either me or but I'm just saying it
should be deductible because it's a
business expense you got to get a select
Jewish accountant to make sure it's
categorized as a business exact you go
to the Supreme Court and tell them it's
not a Supreme Court it's a it's a good
faith argument based on because we're in
a new vertical in terms of business
traditional we don't really fit the
traditional mold of how people spend
money on entertainment like what you're
doing is a legitimate business if you're
not giving out a hundred thousand
dollars people aren't watching your
videos yeah so I see that and I think
it's a good faith a legitimate argument
to make to the IRS that hey this is all
duck table expenses because this is what
you do yeah I guess do you want me to be
your account yeah you want to do
everything for me yeah this [ __ ] gets me
riled up because look it's R it's
ridiculous if you spend that much money
on the video I'm not enriching you it's
[ __ ] you're producing content yeah
but at the same time like some of it
goes to my boys and things like that so
that's deductible yeah or I mean that's
a that's they should pay the taxes on
that yeah so so anyways I buy him a car
and then it's like pee
on this car I gave you that's when they
don't have that's basically summing up
with that we have on it's just like
because they especially because I know a
lot of the prizes that give way that
people can't afford the taxes that's the
dilemma that's crazy man yeah that's a
tough kind of people I think that is a
really interesting peek behind the
curtain yeah the people don't think
about you look to your accountant this
year you as well what else we got here
oh yeah I want to ask you is it true
that this video got claimed for this
part and therefore will my podcast right
now be claimed oh yeah it did actually
I'm not gonna play it but yeah yeah we
got a prayer claimed it we just
literally said living on a prayer but I
have so many instances where I just say
a few words and my videos get claimed
it's so it's worse than it's ever been
yeah well I got it removed because that
tweet cause - oh they dropped it yeah
thank God but they they took like five
figures off the video cuz like even
though they didn't lay it back no you
don't like you don't get it back until
you dispute the process so I didn't
dispute because I didn't know what was
and like okay I don't want to [ __ ] talk
YouTube but they they didn't even a the
it was claimed by living on a prayer but
the name of the song that was claimed
was Miss Brazil talk to him about that
yeah so I didn't know it was living on a
prayer so it was some other song that I
couldn't find so I didn't dispute it for
months and so months this videos racking
up views and they just told me they miss
a label do you know what's happening
these companies are even involved
there's like third party that are
claiming that they have their own box
yeah that are scanning YouTube not using
YouTube's automated system and so they
just sign up these big record labels and
like hey we'll pay a million dollar or
you know yeah well did you see I saw a
tube filter wrote an article this
morning about how now in like a month
they're gonna have to give time stamps
when they manually claim which is all I
ever wanted right yeah so that's gonna
become mandatory in a month and then you
tube even it's funny you bring that up
said they'd prefer people use their own
Content ID instead of outsourcing it so
the literally YouTube address both of it
I mean it sucks you're working on it
yeah they are
I've lost like six figures probably two
claims oh yeah yeah so it's like it's
annoying but but can you imagine like
like sometimes people will claim our
entire to our podcast for like a 5
second clip yeah and these [ __ ]
[ __ ] are making like tens of
thousands of dollars off of all of our
where all of our collective work because
I use five seconds it's something fairly
when you know and when you just like say
words like it's just like you see yeah
it's right it's like that is such a
stretch it blows my mind I'm impressed
that you guys were true enough to pitch
that a bot found that what you guys did
living on a prayer for like five seconds
yeah or like even shorter than that yeah
but a bot recognized that yeah I think
so I don't I don't know like it was
manually claimed oh wow yeah but I think
a bot recognizes and then they go but
when the bot recognizes it gives you
time stance when it's manual claimed at
the mall third-party what if all you
outside of you and then they go and
manually clean yeah them yeah probably
what do they do like download and scrape
it does matter
yeah it all matters everything matters
so what else is there well we hit
thumbnails yeah we hit money we've hit
those two pretty hard is there anything
else in life is there any other meanings
I don't know what do you think what do
you would use it was your purpose uh I
don't know just be happy I've been happy
pretty recently yeah picking up some
other side hobbies I got into basketball
this mellow autobiography and reading
and things like that just if all you do
is make videos I think PewDiePie said it
you're not an interesting person so try
just pick up other stuff to develop
around your cell phone yeah exactly
so that and just uh just chilling good
yeah I'm playing video games you what
books you're reading oh good one well I
gave up on books I tried it but it's
more like self-help or things like if I
want to improve like if I want to sleep
better I listen to a book I like sleep I
like the best
you know like mattress and things like
that it's weird but like any time I want
to improve an area of my life I just
kind of throw in an audiobook because of
social media [ __ ] my attention span I
can read I really tried for like a month
because like PewDiePie reads you know
and so I get inspired every time he does
a book review but then I go to read some
books and after five minutes I'm just
like checking Twitter it's off I think
you got to first find a book that really
captivates you yeah cuz PewDiePie
refusal
of like classical [ __ ] yeah and that's
just not the easiest to get into yeah
like if you could pick up some really
snappy [ __ ] you could probably get
that's you need like a gateway book yeah
to get sucked in yeah yeah no speaking
of what he reads it's like he's
recommended like Jordan Peterson and
[ __ ] or like um like dystopian novels
and things like that yeah no it's
actually really impressive because most
people would like especially like people
who only know him from the media would
probably think he just reads like
[ __ ] [ __ ] but he seems like really
educated person mm-hmm yeah he's smart
dude there's no question about it
do you have trouble sleeping no but I
like to just optimize things cuz like
technically you know you spend so much
of your life sleeping you might as well
you know make sure you get into REM
sleep as fast as possible and optimize
it cuz it does play in your health and
your happiness and if you are like oh
you're like an optimizer by Nature yeah
optimizing things that's interesting how
long do you sleep well that thing is the
videos kind of [ __ ] that up see oh this
is like when we spend 24 hours in a
desert it's like yeah and things like
that but yeah I have no structure for
the otter you might try you don't wake
up at a certain time in the morning um
but for the most part we all get
together on weekdays at 9:00 a.m. that's
pretty early yeah so whatever for that
but like you know now I'm in LA just
doing things so it's weird I wish I had
a little bit more structure so I could
get into rhythm like that's work that's
yeah that's a big problem my life I have
no [ __ ] I have no structure
I think this baby's gonna [ __ ] my life
up though he's gonna structure my ass
real good actually not I told that to my
therapist and he's like actually for
most people baby's unstructured their
life I was like well you can't get any
less structure than I currently are yeah
that's phrase in there man he was
rolling around and [ __ ] I didn't even
imagine that like doing what I would do
now but I mean I'm 20s I've plenty of
done yeah yeah but that would be great
we waited we waited for a while we we
definitely had a few years where we like
couldn't even imagine yeah we knew we
wanted to yeah but we what we waited I
think we are in a good place now - yeah
and it's really nice to work from home
so that we can be with the kid yeah most
people have to like go and do [ __ ]
they're gone all day
yeah damn my pants were in the Army for
25 years like my real yes I didn't any
for most time when I was a kid really
yeah
and where you were probably very close
with the nanny I don't really remember
it's like younger yeah yeah my mom said
I had a fuckload of Legos and I would
just deal with that makes sense that
adds up with your current occupation
yeah but you're both your parents are
military yeah useful military what did
they do in the military I don't know
honestly everyone always asked me that
I've literally never really asked him I
think my mom told me she used to work at
a prison somewhere out like not on in
America so I I don't know to me so [ __ ]
yeah I was eating your mom Oh your mom's
Guantanamo Bay I don't know about that
but I know she's some pretty badass like
sometimes like when you know we have a
lot of employees and stuff she's like
she's a little too rough I'm like mom
this isn't the army calm down I really
should go a boot camp on them a little
bit yeah like just like she's rough you
know what I mean because like a lot of
people and I'm not even talking about my
voice but just in general like people
are like kind of a snowflake so you have
to be a little bit nicer and sometimes
she forgets that you know my mom calm
down
that's funny yeah does she work with you
or does she work yes she does I would
just retire her but I think she kind of
like you know likes working a little bit
sometimes though it's a little too much
but now that we like it's like as I've
gotten bigger and got more people it's
got a little bit me yeah but it's hard
because it's like loyalty and Trust like
I do I don't know who I could just put
as my right-hand person that just like
literally oversees everything in my life
and just trust that they don't [ __ ] me
over
is that what your mom does yeah yeah so
helps manage money and and like things
like from checking all the purchases on
our company cards make sure their
actress so she a salaried employee yeah
interesting
but like no you're right goodbye
whatever she wants like if she wanted a
house like really badly I'd go by her
house you know whatever so you guys are
pretty close on the day today yes like I
see my mom like literally every day wow
that's sweet
that's not [ __ ] that's sweet as hell
yeah well it'll be interesting to see in
five years how it goes yeah like by our
lake house and things like that
go
I can't imagine working with my mom but
it seems like you guys have what like
it's kind of like no choice because like
literally who else could I trust but
you're right I mean it's hard to yeah we
do yeah but that's like on the topic of
trust like everyone like like Chris
Chandler I'll like these people I grew
up with this is great I like him by the
way I want to put that on the record
yeah yeah no he's really good and he
I've known him since I was like 12 and
so it's just like he was actually my
first subscribers so he was their number
one that's another reason why I'd never
moved to LA and that's why I also think
people will struggle if they try to do
what I do because they don't have the
loyalty and stuff like like Jake Paul
it's constantly getting backstabbed
anyone but he kind of he kind of reaps
what he saw yeah but there's other
people to like that are just always well
it's rare I think in general though it
is rare to find a group a tight group of
dudes that can work harmoniously
together like over a long period like
sometimes like really late nights and
stuff like that but then that's what I
would recommend though if people are
trying to do what I do like you gotta go
to your roots and like hire people you
know because like you're getting a
random guy in LA like there's a
literally like a coin flip that they're
just gonna [ __ ] you over one day oh my
god more than a coin flip yeah it's like
a rig the dice roll exactly so but
you're not always fortunate like a good
group of friends that live near you and
you can work together well I think you
learn when you're hiring as we have over
time there there's obviously a lot of
techniques to figuring out the right
people
that's why HR is such a many big
companies have like huge HR resources
and departments just for like vetting
people you know it's like it is a real
skill it's just different for our
industry because like you could
literally just say one mean thing to
them and then they turn out and quit and
make a video and like ruin your career
that's true so it's like it just gets
really messy because everyone can use
social media that's true
so it's it's a miracle that I've gotten
this far without you know yeah so that's
why I try to incorporate them on a lot
of challenges and stuff like just
because they've been awesome as I've
been one of your big challenges
finding kind of the people right people
to work with oh yeah 100 million percent
like because it's a lot of time it's a
lot of everything and it's just like the
loyalties huge like I'd rather like
Ethan one of our editors he wasn't super
passionate about editing but like he's
someone I knew like since middle school
so we like ya over time he's gotten
better but we had to like kind of work
with them and train got it in hand yeah
yeah cuz I just wanted lil T I'd rather
have a guy I can trust for the next 10
years so he's the one that's editing
everything now one of them yeah we have
like three anything's pretty good yeah
good happy well one thing we do is like
we I have like they'll edit the video
and they're like Chris will review it
and then Chandler and then they and then
I'll review it at the end and make notes
and once you do all like five revision
Wow it's impossible for it not to be
like yeah see you got a tight you got a
tight operation there am i dude yeah I'm
lucky honestly I am it's it's great
you're lucky but you're also you are
talent you're hard-working dude you're
smart dude well in its I don't wanna
it's it's hard because like a lot of
people just see where I am now but like
if you saw like the build-up of it like
it was it was hard like it was really
rough because no one's ever really done
well I did and I had like no money and
like I just making [ __ ] bad as I went I
was a teenager and it's just like this
whole thing is like there's a 50-50
chance I ran out of money like two years
ago and now this work you know so a
little bit of luck yeah and now here you
are putting 100 million Orbeez and my
manager back yeah god bless it's fun
times
well we've said it all in the words of
Howard Stern we've done it all you've
said it all um I didn't say what my
favorite color was but besides that is
it um blue nice I don't know why people
say like that question though people ask
but I feel like it's so lucky that I've
heard it like a few times I haven't
heard interviews someplace as to what
you know nobody asked me like what the
[ __ ] that matter it was five yeah but if
you want to really want to know I wanted
mine is purple really I find purple to
be a really beautiful lush
I can't tell special color yeah a lot of
all colors but it's stupid it's like
well favorite color it's a five year old
yeah what's your favorite number yeah
that's what about what's your favorites
pubic hair the purple really I think I
do think purple is a very special color
it is very nice I like that green of
your hat people are watching they're
like hey no I won't do that
I'm I want to show you some stuff here's
a segment we're gonna end on this note
okay
it's called weird dad's all right an
honor of my forthcoming child David
first we've got Tom Brady kisses his son
on the mouth throat oh my god have you
seen this so I watched this and again
I'm not I'm not judging the guy you know
I mean a man his relationship with a son
there's a special sacred thing on the
other hand just watch this video oh I
haven't seen this one oh so he this is
something he's known for doing right oh
because I saw the clip of him on the
field right kissing a son so this is a
different one here watch this enjoy this
thank you I'm glad so the kid goes I
want can I check my fantasy team and he
says what do I get
he said it like would whack yeah and
then he comes the kid comes and gives
him a peck and he goes that was just a
peck wait did you actually hear much
yeah I don't want to see that in the
wrong place that was like a peck man I
was a bet ref place to pause oh yeah
honestly I think there's like a 60%
chance something comes out in ten years
I don't think so I know you're kidding
yeah but man but man that's a that's
gonna [ __ ] that kid up and the kid is
like wiping his mouth yeah you're not
gonna make out with your kid I never
kissed my parents on the lips i I've
always found the parent kissing on the
lips to be one of the strangest
phenomenons I've ever known especially
like especially over the age of like I
mean I don't know like five yeah I don't
know I mean I mean when they're like a
cute little puppy you know I understand
that but as a like a little like 13 year
old I will agree that is not okay
yeah yeah okay well what's the next clue
you said you had a few yes that more yes
I have more are you what are you in a
hurry to take uh kissing the child off
are we established that is inappropriate
that we tackle the next clue you just
you're just trying to analyze it's
trying to the podcast what is this one
oh so this is again weird weird parents
there's this one's [ __ ] weird bro at
a pep rally I can tell about dislikes
it's gonna be so at a pep rally they
inferred the whole school they prank the
sports players by bringing their parents
in their mom's into kit would they
blindfold them and then their mom comes
and makes out with them in front of the
whole school
what that school needs to lose its
funding watch this yet hi captains
received a kiss from a special someone
that's the dad oh my god the dad oh my
god those are all parents making out and
they don't know it oh and then this mom
but it's like hands on her ass one of
the most they're on the floor making out
and then this mom you see that you
should moved his hand onto her ass right
here I'm not kidding
watch this really you know for sure
she's got a whole this of course she's
[ __ ] her kid look look at her green
vascular you don't now they're like how
did you enjoy the kid did one of those
this is one of the most [ __ ] things
yeah yeah that's terrible like I would
put those kids on like suicide watch
like that's that's as embarrassing as it
gets it literally doesn't get you you
make out with your mom in front of your
whole high school there's way too much
like did they find also like all these
parents to agree to do that this is like
this is a weird town like I don't know
where this is I wouldn't like it that
popped in my head paying people $10,000
gets their mom but that sounds like some
stupid no it's so that's twisted
yeah yeah no that's because you know a
prank invasion would yeah yeah if you
have you pay some like ten bucks though
made a new video today or it was a
yesterday called making out with my
sister but it's obviously super fake and
I'm never gonna watch it very funny if
that was the next one on the list weird
yeah without one with that one blew me
away I mean that's right you got all I
was a weird one but now let's keep going
here because we got Billy Baldwin he
gets worse it doesn't get worse than
that okay good Billy Baldwin tweeted and
again I think he's just being sweet but
it just reads very funny just spent the
last hour if my arms wrapped around my
giant six for 17 year old son no phones
no words just silence breathing bonding
best hour I've had
grateful it's like it's hard to say that
without like trying to sound soothing to
like it does it sounds seductive
yeah and I'm and I think he just I think
he may be just warded it a little funny
because I loved I loved it the way he
goes Mike giant six-point 17 year old
son just silence breathing
it sounds like they had some good
cuddling yeah I get yeah I like that too
look at the top moment just spent 72
hours biscotti my son's bps and weeping
no bones I wish we could read more
replies but there's some gold did yeah
he erased it so he bounced on this one
he erased it after like four days though
like out there for a while it's getting
roasted by everybody because he's proud
yeah I can see this one being completely
on it innocent it I'm sure was yeah it
just sounds funny you should have the
people comment which was worse Tom Brady
kissing his son on the lips well no
actually it's not a question the Prep
Rally
well the Prep Rally that's not wins a
landslide yeah but actually we could do
live but there's nobody watching let's
take a poll out back there which is
worse Tom Brady making out with the Sun
or the Prep Rally pep rally okay yeah
the the pep rally hands down sheepishly
pep rally yes I'm ashamed to admit is
that all them come yeah that's it but I
love that Tom Brady just a pic I want to
get those sound bites that's like and
then the masseuse said he goes
everything comes with a cost
yeah the guy massaging Tom Brady goes
you know everything comes with a cost
you must have like great here I can well
because you were you were trying to
optimize and so if you keep playing I
can make out sessions you're very
sensitive to son and though I'm not a
you know insulted by that I'm okay with
that
like you take you're not yeah if like
people tell me that I don't like
watching dad
sons kiss yeah I don't mind you don't
take that as an insolence yeah so it's
good keep your head up your optimistic
guy yeah I'm confident and my dad's on
kissing police well you've said it all
including your favorite color you've
come down to LA and conquered YouTube in
a short time you are mister not really
short time but well you know in my Ryder
life from your rise you've climbed you
have conquered you have or beed you a
beast beasts moded it and now I learned
that I need to build a house out of
Orbeez do it and do it right yep poor
for Iceland dude for Iceland dude so
guys thank you all for watching this has
been the beast mode check them out at
mr. beast that's his YouTube channel if
you don't know him more just subscribe
to divide that be preferred yes
did he didn't lose yet it's a few times
I always bounce back it's annoying
because you want it just like tweet out
like a pissed removal flag yeah but you
like you can cuz you know yeah the
insanity continues and there you have it
next week we have a slow mo guys wait no
but there's no that will have already
happened yeah yeah oh [ __ ] so we have
slow mo guys oh that was such a good
episode was now I love Gary Gavin Gavin
yeah yeah sweetheart he was super fun in
that
so who do we have after about Gus
Johnson will be really yes no that's
cool cuz Lakes weeks Gus Jones he's not
like super big but I like that you have
him like he's still an interesting
person he did oh yeah he didn't want
where like they delivered packages or
whatever it was like him kickin it and
luckily just through that the door that
was really fun yeah he's funny he's
great he's a talent and we will be
having him next week cool and we will be
having the two previous weeks just for
my own mental collections and who do we
have in the next two previous weeks just
confusing that's weak
the previous weeks we just had slow mo
guys the previous and then and then
afterwards the top of the or us doing
our own thing no oh you have an M on
yeah I agree
I like her a lot cuz like she's like
younger so yeah like how high school and
stuff like that work I'm fascinated by
everything about her I think she's a
really interesting person a real
talented person and I'm looking forward
to speaking with her we end this show we
have outro music we really start it like
several times no but we've said it all
we've done it all alright guys so next
week we will I don't know it's difficult
for watching everybody
appreciate you and thanks for watching
thank you much
[Music]